nous avons des présidents avant de la 5e
vainqueur il ya charles de saint georges
pompidou en ballet russe carrière à la
peau et qui a été deux fois président de
la république sans jamais avoir été élu
[Musique]
charles de gaulle
la réponse est
[Musique]
c'est vrai alors
et bien c'est jean-charles là qui fait
tomber
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui vous faites quoi dans la
vision charme je suis actuellement poids
d'accord avait 22 ans
vous habitez en bretagne c'est ça non
non non vous avez déménagé il a gagné un
week-end gastronomique en bretagne et
8150 euros il paraît quand vous avez une
mine épaules est ce que c'est vrai que
le public pleurer dans et que vous avez
reçues même des messages d'insultés à
huy ha vu d'ailleurs mon public un tout
à fait monsieur marc paul était il était
beaucoup enfin il était mais bien sûr et
donc ils savent pas moins qu'ils étaient
là et effectivement j'ai eu quelques
petits messages
bon j'avais des messages bien eu les
deux les fans de paul qui chiemsee
bonfils station quand même mais je suis
très triste que paul soit parti ouais et
eu d'autres messages un peu un peu moins
gentil effectivement alors vous auriez
la bonne réponse pour la question par
émulation oui parce que en fait vu que
c'est jamais enfin savoir été élu
j'aurais dit su que je connais pas quoi
parce qu'ils apprécient
voilà et dites moi paul penser qu'il la
connaissait pas la réponse mais mû comme
ça par élimination bah moi je ne sais
pas du tout s'il la connaissaient ou pas
mais en tout cas moi derrière j'ai pu
lui parler un petit peu a pas les poches
il était quand même vrai il était agacé
quand même d'avoir été éliminée - outre
à elle était agacé comme d'abord été
éliminés même taquiné tout ça voilà
parce que le pouvoir de l'avoir éliminé
donc et plus en duel donc effectivement
je pense que il était quand même agacé
d'être parti donc je pense pas qu'ils
alors il explique qu'il ya une rumeur
qui a dit que paul aurait eu une pensée
pour christian quesada après son
élimination est que cette séquence avait
été coupée au montage
il en a parlé ou pas du tout je vais pas
dire j'y étais toujours sa réponse
voilà donc c'est une fameuse rumeur se
place assez bien le dire moi j'ai écrit
ben moi aussi j'ai connu comme sa ferme
et non pas du tout c'est une connerie là
il a tout ay là il a pas dû des
digressions qu'ils allaient du juste qui
va là
et vous étiez fan de lui vous êtes dit
je veux aller à les éliminer paul alors
c'est clément plus qui a souvent des
bonnes infos mais là et voilà ben afan
oui bah je le suivais un petit peu dans
l'émission effectivement et
je savais pas si l'être encore ici ou
pas un moment j'étais l'émission mais
effectivement quand j'ai vu je suis dit
bon on va jouer et puis voici sa part
estimé sa bosse pas voir voilà on
rentrera et puis soir était une belle
aventure
et puis effectivement il y avait ce qui
arrivait alors sur les réseaux
sélectionneur qui vous ont un peu
critique et emballe pas à jean charles
dans deux jours tu es plus là l'homme le
plus détesté de france
je déteste dans charlesbourg voilà nous
disent vous dit vraiment voilà ils vous
ont dit ça et paul il a fait son
discours donc il n'a pas parlé de ça
mais c'est vrai que c'était on voit
qu'il est déçu dans son discours et
surtout poli laferrère pas mal de monde
quand il a été éliminé
c'était juste après il était dans le
public et sa réponse à jean luc
reichmann et mighty crown à bravo paul
ça va quand même col ouais ouais ouais
ça fait quoi d'être dans le public là ça
fichiers bercy c'était le mot de paul
et il était déçu mais effectivement
cette phrase il aurait peut-être pas dit
je pense pas qu'il aurait dit si leur
était pas pas été vraiment déçu et était
sincère et puis même derrière voilà il
m'a et s'amuser à me taquiner comme je
disais c'est vrai que je pense vraiment
qu'il était sincère quand il car vous
vous avez été éliminés mardi pendant
l'épreuve du coup fatal en fait mais
surtout je m'en veux un petit peu parce
que c'est un peu à cause des mois que
vous avez perdu ma relance à regarder
plus d'un an
comment est le ba ba quand il des phases
aux roms mais qu'il porte des pattes
d'eph et des cheveux longs pas baba cool
en peinture quelle couleur est associée
à la sanguine
j'ai pas moins aujourd'hui encore un
coup de tonnerre au dos ou traîné
l'homme qui a fait tomber vol après 5 e
participation vous demander votre casier
judiciaire si vous aviez un casier
judiciaire avant oui bah un moment des
vacances inscrit donc on doit donner
plusieurs papiers à ce qui est normal et
effectivement on doit de même extrait du
casier judiciaire ça s'il est vierge et
dont vous avez dû donner un extrait de
votre casier judiciaire fallait bien
jean charles voilà on a eu les réponses
on se pose et voilà sur paul et jean
charles merci
[Applaudissements]